vamos a empezar
qué pregunta quiénes somos en nuestras
redes sociales quiero presentaros hoy
agustina pero quiero presentar la
versión que las redes sociales presentan
de mí he seleccionado algunos posteos
que habitualmente realizo me considero
una muy activa usuaria de redes sociales
tanto en lo profesional como en lo
personal veamos un poco el contenido que
subo habitualmente que lo pueden
encontrar no he mentido ese es el
contenido que yo realmente estuvo
relacionado bueno el amor propio me
gusta mucho a los gatos así que van a
ver mucho contenido relacionado de los
felinos relacionado también al cuidado
del medio ambiente y mi gata preciosa
que es una belleza
y también comparto sobre mi trabajo como
saben soy licenciada en comunicación y
me especializo en marketing y dirección
comercial en esta oportunidad en esta
imagen
se trata de un conversatorio que
realizamos hace dos años en la
universidad donde estábamos hablando de
el mundo digital en la comunicación y en
el periodismo recuerdo haber asesorado
en ese momento ya a los estudiantes y
decirles la oportunidad de empezar a
optimizar y mejorar su identidad digital
para poder ellos también tener mejores
oportunidades y mejores posibilidades
prácticamente es lo que vengo a hacer
también hoy acá en esta charla
hablar de identidad digital es hablar de
lo que estamos construyendo
constantemente con todo el contenido que
nosotros subimos directa o
indirectamente en las redes tenemos que
pensar que nos mostramos como si fuera
un triángulo donde tenemos una foto un
nombre y una biografía que tienen igual
importancia los tres lados
debemos pensar como si estuviéramos por
ir a buscar trabajo en la experiencia de
buscar trabajo vamos y seguramente nos
recomiendan que tengamos una buena foto
que tengamos nuestras habilidades bien
digamos bien redactadas bien descriptas
y también nuestra formación académica
sin embargo lo que muy pocos nos dicen
es que tenemos que cuidar lo que está en
las redes sociales sobre nosotros porque
porque tiene que existir una coherencia
entre lo que mostramos en redes con lo
que mostramos también en un currículum
en muchas oportunidades
mi carrera de periodista escuché a
muchas empresas decir que no contrataban
a las personas por lo que veían en sus
redes sociales no las contrataba así que
tenemos que tener una importancia o sea
una una red de importancia a todo lo que
estamos compartiendo para rich hoffman
el fundador de linkin considera que en
las redes sociales se pueden visualizar
los pecados capitales' facebook sería el
ego y linkin sería la avaricia y la
codicia por la forma en la que nos
mostramos en las redes como saben no sé
si son usuarios muy activos en ambas nos
vamos a mostrar de una manera distinta
en facebook nos vamos a mostrar de una
manera más informal vamos a compartir
contenido entretenimiento pero en linkin
vamos a buscar compartir contenido
profesional relacionado a las empresas
es importante saber que toda esta
información no se genera de un minuto a
otro sino que ya se estuvo generando
desde nuestros inicios en este mundo
digital y que se encuentran almacenados
en lo que se conoce como la gran nube
digital de datos que aloja absolutamente
toda la información que ustedes tienen
en sus dispositivos tecnológicos o sea
celulares computadoras relojes cualquier
dispositivo que les esté solicitando un
email para poder acceder lo que ustedes
tienen que realmente considerar cuando
comparten esta información es que toda
esta información está ya constituyendo
una identidad digital se preguntarán qué
es una identidad digital básicamente es
todo lo que hace es lo que decís y lo
que mostrar en tus redes
directa o indirectamente tanto para bien
perfecto hermoso como para mal
por eso tenemos que tener en
consideración que toda la información
que compartimos ya está generando una
huella y una identificación de nosotros
ahora bien esta presentación que realicé
de mí para contarles un poco de lo que
comparte de lo que me gusta lo podría
hacer de cualquier perfil de ustedes
puedo evaluar su perfil ver cinco o
cuatro con contenidos de ustedes con
posteos comentarios y hacer una
percepción una identificación de lo que
son ustedes
será real o no pero ya la puedo hacer
habitualmente en mi trabajo
asesoró a emprendedores y a marcas en
donde buscamos tener mucha información
sobre nuestros clientes y nuestros
prospectos que serían potenciales
potenciales clientes
buscamos toda esta información y vamos
creando avatares estos avatares son como
personajes ficticios que le damos un
nombre que le damos características para
que para qué sirven los avatares
principalmente sirven para para que
estas empresas puedan mejorar su
propuesta de valor puedan tener una
estrategia más diferenciada puedan
posicionarse mejor en el mercado esto
relacionado al marketing
pero estos avatares le podemos dar un
nombre y mucho más si quieres lo hacemos
al ejercicio ahora que estamos
le pongo un nombre acá le puse camila
díaz decimos sus características
principales de dónde es que hace su
poder adquisitivo lo que le gusta lo que
consume lo que sueña lo que no le gusta
lo que le angustia y lo que la está
frustrando
cuando trabajamos con las marcas y los
emprendedores básicamente cuando
construimos la propuesta de valor
pensamos en lo que le angustia y en lo
que quiere conseguir porque porque es
así cuando las marcas y los grandes los
grandes líderes y los gran las grandes
empresas van a poder ofrecer soluciones
mucho más personalizadas y más eficaces
por eso toda esta información que se va
obteniendo para crear estos avatares de
dónde se obtiene
se obtiene de investigaciones de mercado
que realizan las principales consultoras
del mundo se obtienen de informes que se
realizan sobre el comportamiento del
consumidor que ya se encuentran en
motores de búsqueda se encuentran
también en las redes sociales porque
ellos nos ofrecen una forma algo que
tenemos cuentas comerciales nos ofrecen
informes sobre los datos y sobre las
estadísticas del público que se maneja
pero también se genera de esta manera
que lo estamos haciendo todos en
realidad cada vez que utilizamos
nuestros dispositivos tecnológicos cada
vez que usamos el celular que ponemos
que nos gusta un restaurante que nos
suscribimos a un canal de youtube que
buscamos algo en el motor de búsqueda de
google
cada vez que utilizas el celular si
ustedes van a decir es muchísima la
información que estamos dando
seguramente antes de venir acá tienen
activada la ubicación y ya dejaron mucha
información hasta capaz que ahora lo
están haciendo en sus redes sociales
compartiendo en donde están
ante tanta información ustedes piensan
se tiene control ante tanta información
que estamos dejando todo el tiempo
ustedes creen que no
en parte
tenemos la posibilidad de tener ese
control con el conocimiento de saber que
esos datos están alojados en un lugar
donde a veces si es bastante atareado el
ponerse a leer términos y condiciones
las configuraciones que nos dicen
facebook o instagram que tenemos que
leer pero lo tenemos que hacer
recordemos la situación que pasó hace
poquito con whatsapp
what's up tuvo que retroceder y
postergar su actualización
ustedes leyeron la actualización que
ellos estaban solicitando bien
decidieron retroceder esta medida pero
no la anularon porque la van a hacer en
mayo se estaba se están preparando pero
el objetivo la situación particular que
quiero destacar les es cómo se comportó
el consumidor el consumidor dijo bueno
whatsapp quiere actualizar su política
de datos quiere empezar a compartir toda
la información que nosotros estamos
dando en whatsapp para también
compartirla con facebook con messenger
con instagram que como sabemos todos son
de la misma empresa y del mismo dueño
sin mark zuckenberg pero la gente
decidió por influencia de grandes
líderes del mundo como el on mask dijo
no me voy a la competencia me voy a
asignar me voy a telegram el usuario
decidió muchas veces esto no lo tomamos
en conciencia cuando lo hacemos
pero los números de telegrama se
duplicaron después de esta medida de
actualización de whatsapp
el control es posible como les dije la
identidad se va creando directa o
indirectamente así que hay muchas cosas
que no vamos a poder controlar pero hay
muchas otras que sí
tenemos que pensar como si estuviéramos
en un supermercado eso es algo que
hacemos todos y nosotros sabemos que hay
una infinidad de productos con
diferentes presentaciones precios pero
nosotros igual decidimos a dónde vamos y
qué decidimos hasta sabemos no sé si
todos saben acá técnicas que ya utiliza
el marketing tradicional con respecto a
la infraestructura del lugar que ponen
los alimentos por ejemplo que no son
deseados como las golosinas de las ponen
al frente para que cuando vayas a
comprar te pp que es detente es y la
compres es uno lo ya lo sabe pero igual
lo hace uno igual compra la golosina
pero hay gente que no hay gente que dice
no yo voy a superar esa esa manipulación
esa persuasión que está haciendo el
marketing tradicional para que yo no
compre eso
esta es una acción que todos compartimos
pero yo quiero compartir que podemos
hacerlo siendo más responsables de la
información y de los datos que
compartimos optimizando nuestra
identidad leyendo estos términos y
condiciones en mi trabajo habitualmente
me dedico a leer bastante
configuraciones en redes sociales por
diferentes actualizaciones que
estuvieron realizando el año pasado para
los para las marcas comerciales han
aumentado un sinfín de configuraciones
por eso sé que puede ser atareado pero
en realidad es algo que todos deberíamos
tomarnos el tiempo para hacer
recuerden que los gatos tanto su
tratamiento su formato y su divulgación
son unos de los recursos más importantes
que tenemos en este siglo por eso
nosotros tenemos que tratar de que toda
esta información que estamos otorgando
voluntariamente porque nadie nos está
obligando a que lo hagamos
este a nuestro favor
como podemos hacer
en primer en primera instancia reconocer
que esta identidad digital se está
gestando ya en este momento todos lo
estamos haciendo y podemos mejorar
nuestras posibilidades y nuestras
oportunidades optimizando la como
reconociendo que es una identidad social
porque es la forma en la que
interactuamos con los demás es una
identidad valiosa porque nos puede
ofrecer buenas oportunidades a todos
todos queremos conseguir mejores
oportunidades de trabajo
queremos mejorar nuestros ingresos
teniendo tiendas en facebook o en
instagram queremos mejor mejorar nuestro
posicionamiento en google podemos
hacerlo es subjetiva porque obviamente
se está gestionando a veces tras la
mirada de ese otro que está viendo
nuestras redes y ustedes ya generaron
una percepción de mí con el contenido
que yo les mostré
y es fragmentada porque en cada red
social nos mostramos de forma distinta
si en instagram vamos a subir un tipo de
contenido si es que tenemos cuenta
personal o comercial muy diferente si
subimos como les decía en interés o en
linkin y es real porque esta identidad
influye en nuestras vidas de forma
positiva o negativa pero influye en lo
personal tengo que destacar que gracias
a las redes y gracias a poder optimizar
mis redes y mi identidad digital me
animé a emprender me animé a enamorarme
y me animé a ser mucho más libre
económicamente y en muchísimos aspectos
los dejo con la pregunta ustedes saben
quiénes son en sus redes
gracias